it's september 1st 2021 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
i'll tell you about what went on in
august that you might have missed and
would want to check out and what we've
got coming up in this busy month of
september so three big things to kick
things off uh big thing number one
classes are starting again so i'll tell
you a little bit more about that in the
august and the september parts of this
big thing number two stoicon is coming
up in october so you're going to see a
lot of things coming out this month of
september as we're gearing up for this
online event that's open to everybody
if you're at all interested
in how we adapt an ancient philosophy to
modern times and its problems you don't
want to miss stoicon 21 which i happen
to be one of the organizers with along
with my wife and partner andy
big thing number three
you're going to see a lot of videos on
one of my favorite series uh fantasy
series the earthsea
trilogy i don't know if we'll actually
get through all the the trilogy this
month by ursula k le guin
because i am teaching a class that has
already started on leguin's earthsea in
which we're going through the entire
set of novels and short stories so
you'll you'll start seeing some things
on wizard of earth see probably
coming out tomorrow those are the three
big things let's talk now about what
went on in august
so august was a big month i had a
birthday i turned 51 so it wasn't a big
birthday like number 50 was last year
but i had a good time and a lot of
people wished me well and so that was
kind of nice
some of my classes have started i'm
teaching three classes this semester
the two for milwaukee institute of art
and design began last week with
my ethics for artisan designers which is
a completely online asynchronous class
and then my class that i just mentioned
on ursula k leguins earth c stuff where
we're applying some
some stuff from philosophy and some
other disciplines to look at her
great narrative universe and
stories these are things that i've been
reading since i was a middle schooler
i'm very attached to them so that's been
a lot of fun we also got to and when i
say we i mean my my wife andy and i we
got out on the town a little bit
we
went to the van gogh immersive
exhibition called beyond van gogh and
that was incredibly
moving
we were fortunate in that we could just
walk across the street to the wisconsin
center to see it
we also went to a gala and i wore a tux
you may have seen some of the pictures
first time that i've been in a tux i
think since prom
um so that was you know that was an
interesting experience and that was
actually a lot of fun we are you know
we're members of the
milwaukee county zoo and so we try to
support as much as we can
i did a lot of online events we didn't
do the the heavy metal class due to some
scheduling issues but i did do
the worlds of speculative fiction
focusing on
a van vote and his weapon makers
stories and we did the ama we did the
hegel events i did a lot of live
readings from my book which i'll just
hold up here
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
so if you're interested in that i'll put
a link to that below as well as to the
many readings that we did we i think we
hit every single thursday this month so
we're making some good progress through
the book
i also interestingly did some podcast
appearances as a guest that are not yet
out but you'll see them coming out
pretty soon for the open door podcast
and the existential stoic podcast
a lot of course building a lot of course
designing i have one class that's
beginning
next week business ethics that i'm
teaching for carthage college online as
well i'm not teaching face-to-face
anywhere
this semester so
and i managed to do some writing as well
not as much as i would have liked but
some and so i'm going to try to continue
that trend
going forward
videos this was a month where i finally
for the first time in a long time was
able to do six half-hour hegel videos
and make some good progress through the
phenomenology that we are reaching the
end of you know i've been doing this
half hour hegel project for seven and a
half years now
so you know it's time to bring it to a
successful conclusion but the only way
is through plowing through
all of these videos there is also of
course the speculative fiction
uh videos that i i started doing this
month some on ursula k le guin not on
uh a wizard of earthsea quite yet but i
did do two earthsea stories and her from
elf land to poughkeepsie and i did some
on philip jose farmer's the lovers as
well very famous science fiction story
almost infamous for some people who
thought it was smut
we talk about why that's not actually
the case i did a book review i was
hoping to get to more but i i wasn't
able to do
more than that i also did a video
compiling the i would tell a joke and
then they say something about a
philosopher
from twitter
i did a video as well for stoicon 2021
so if you want to know what's going on
with stoicon watch that video i'll link
to it below
and uh everybody's invited and you can
you can donate as much or as little as
you'd like it's an online event it's
open to everybody
i cannot recommend it highly enough to
you because we've got a really amazing
lineup of speakers workshop providers
panelists and it's going to be really
quite
uh we i released two wisdom for life
show recording videos that's my radio
show that i do with dan hayes
i also did a sadler's stories one that's
a little bit gruesome about getting my
wisdom teeth pulled and i managed to get
a few core concept videos done in
particular those on michelle foucault
and he has the subject in power which
i'll be continuing uh this coming month
podcast i i released quite a few podcast
episodes in the sadler's lectures
podcast on simone de bevoir on john
sellers my friend and colleague on
thomas aquinas and on aleister mcintyre
so that's that's what went on in august
it's pretty busy
month
all right what do we have coming up in
the month of september it's pretty
packed month so starting on the 4th at
12 p.m central time all times r central
time so make sure to check your time
zones we have the ama that's the ask me
anything online session that's your
opportunity to ask me all the questions
that people often put on youtube videos
that aren't relevant to the video
following that at 2 p.m on the 4th we
have our patreon exclusive philosophy
chat if you want to get in on that
become a patreon supporter at the level
on the 8th at 5 p.m we have the public
hegel q a that's open to everybody who's
got questions about hegel
german idealism philosophy in general
that's a video conferencing session
then uh we'll have the first of the live
readings on the 9th at 12 pm that is an
online event where i am reading from my
book reason fulfilled by revelation the
1930s christian philosophy debates in
france that weekend on the 11th at 12
and at 1 30 p.m we're gonna have the two
portions of the worlds of speculative
fiction this month is a big anniversary
for stannis law lem so we're going to
talk about solaris and i'll probably
bring in some other stuff as well to
talk about then on the 16th at 12 pm my
time later in the evening for them i
will be giving a presentation at stoicon
x oslo
one of the first stoicon x's of the
season these are smaller events hosted
by local communities and that should be
a lot of fun on the 18th at 12 p.m i'll
be joined by my friend and colleague
scott taruli for classic metal class
that's one that's free open to the
public anybody can join in and we'll be
talking some philosophy music history
and classic metal
we'll be having another live reading on
the 23rd at 12 p.m from my book on the
26th at 12 p.m we'll have the political
theory and practice discussion i still
have to decide on a topic for that we've
put that off for a couple months but we
will be having it this time on the 30th
we have the last two events the live
reading and that'll be at noon and then
at 6 00 pm the mke that's milwaukee
stoic fellowship meeting in which we'll
be discussing cicero's on the ends book
two wisdom for life the radio show that
my friend and colleague dan hayes and i
produce is moving to a new bi-weekly
time slot on every other saturday at 5
00 pm we're going to be recording some
new stuff for that
and you know as i mentioned we got
classes going on i'm going to be
teaching quite a bit of
interesting stuff and developing some
new resources for that at all and maybe
doing some writing about what's going on
in my classes video production of course
i'm going to try to produce my six half
hour hegel now that i've got some you
know wind in my sails and i want to get
to some of those book reviews as well
and maybe shoot a few more personal
videos
some follow-up videos but i'm also going
to be doing some core concept videos
finishing out the sequence on the
subject in power and if i get through
that and i've got enough time to spare
i'm going to do some videos as well on
schopenhauer i know people have been
looking forward to that for a long time
the other thing that i'm going to be
doing though is putting out a lot of
content on ursula k leguins earth sea
beginning with a wizard of earth see and
then we'll see how far we can get into
the tombs of ottawa
as my students are reading their way
through this
we've also got the podcast going on i'm
going to finish out the releasing the
mcintyre podcast episodes then i need
some things on mills on liberty for my
ethics for artisan designers class and
also for the business ethics class and i
think i'll concentrate too on doing
quite a few of those shorts that people
seem to like that are about you know
applying philosophy to life in five to
seven minute little clips other than
that going to be doing a lot of writing
in medium and moving some things over
from my other blogs to to medium where i
think they can find a good home
you know we've got stoicon coming up
you're going to see lots and lots of
announcements
i'd like everybody to join me if you
have any interest whatsoever in stoicism
and you want to see what's going on and
hear some great speakers and participate
in some cool
you know interactive things you you
don't want to miss it so that's it for
this coming month and hopefully i'll see
you in some of these online events that
we have lined up
you